These days there can be so much happening
in a movie that it takes a few passes to soak
everything in.
Often we notice something out of the corner
of our eye but before we can fully realize
what it is, the scene changes.
And in these moments, the pause button is
a real blessing.
Other times though, the practice is used for
more, ahem, “educational” reasons.
Before we hop into the list we wanted to thank
you for watching, and invite you to check
out our YouTube channel for more videos like
this one.
You can even sign up to be notified when we
post new content!
Here are 10 Paused Scenes That Take Movies
To Another Level.
Fight Club
There are a few ‘blink and you’ll miss
it’ moments scattered throughout Fight Club,
so it’s best to keep your eyes peeled.
Brad Pitt’s character Tyler is introduced,
among other things, as someone who splices
frames of porn into family movies.
But he’s not the only one doing some crafty
editing.
Director David Fincher made strategic edits
of his own, and those watching closely will
see a brief flash of Tyler in the background
of four scenes.
It’s so subtle that each time it happens
you’ll wonder if you ever saw anything at
all.
Fast Times at Ridgemont High
Admit it: you knew this was coming.
If getting out of the pool was an Olympic
sport, Phoebe Cates would take gold every
time.
Easily the most recognizable, Fast Times at
Ridgemont High gave the world a movie cliché
that’s been used countless times since.
Cates and the infamous red bikini have been
turning heads since the movies release in
1982.
The scene featured heavily in the trailer,
and it doesn’t take a marketing degree to
understand why.
Even though the sequence ends rather traumatically
for one of the characters, the audience can’t
look away.
Scanners
David Cronenberg’s 1981 psychic thriller
Scanners takes a look at what could happen
if telepathists waged war on each other.
Not only can these groups read minds, they
can control them too.
With an ability known as “scanning,” the
characters could make someone’s head explode
if they wanted to.
And luckily for the audience, that’s exactly
what happens.
The FX department filled a hollow gelatin
replica of the actor’s head with fake blood,
chunks, and the food scraps from the day’s
lunch.
For the iconic take, the team used a shotgun
and blasted the replica from below to create
the messy, bloody explosion the movie is so
famous for.
Basic Instinct
After the release of Basic Instinct, Sharon
Stone became a household name.
Her masterful portrayal of crime novelist
slash murderer, Catherine, stood out for lots
of reasons.
Chief among them is one of the sexiest moments
in Silver Screen history: the leg cross.
During an interrogation, Stone seems to flash
her goods at the committee.
Several actresses passed on the role before
she was cast- and this scene might have had
something to do with it.
But, as per usual, Stone made it her own,
and has been cast in countless sexy roles
since.
Including a 2006 sequel cleverly named Basic
Instinct 2.
Iron Man
When the MCU was just a baby, nobody could
have predicted it would grow up to be a herculean
cinematic institution.
Despite a loyal comic book fanbase, critics
were skeptical about wether or not audiences
would get behind versions of Marvel characters
on the big screen.
And then Iron Man happened.
The silver-tongued Stark slithered his way
into our hearts, and made room for a new team
of heroes.
Eagle-eyed viewers got a glimpse into the
future when they noticed part of what looks
like Captain America’s shield in the background
of a scene.
Sometimes paying attention is worth it.
Total Recall
For many people, the only thing better than
two boobs, is three boobs.
And if that sounds like it might be your jam,
check out the 1990 Arnold Schwarzenegger classic
Total Recall.
The triple-breasted mutant Mary was played
by actress Lycia Naff, who spent eight hours
in the makeup chair every single morning.
The prosthetic extended from neck to hips
and gave the actress an otherworldly appearance
that still sends viewers scrambling for the
remote.
Others argue the character’s depiction is
just another classic case of Hollywood setting
unrealistic body standards for young women.
Boogie Nights
Boogie Nights is famous for one scene and
one scene only.
And you’ll know it when you see it.
When Mark Wahlberg signed on for the movie,
he knew there would be some degree of nudity
involved.
After all, it’s a movie about porn.
But the actor wanted to keep some things private.
That wasn’t a problem since there are entire
departments devoted to protecting a performer’s
dignity.
Tricky camera angles, body doubles, and prosthetics
are all ways to maintain the illusion of nudity
on a shoot.
Wahlberg was so impressed with his particular
prop that he stole it once shooting wrapped.
The Lion King
When it comes to Disney, tales of devious
animators permeate almost every conspiracy
theory.
Accusations of subliminal messaging and brainwashed
youth, however far flung, have made even the
most casual bystanders raise an eyebrow.
One scene in 1994’s The Lion King added
fuel to the fire.
As Simba lays down on the edge of a cliff,
he kicks up some dust that dissolves in the
air.
At least, that’s what it looks like to most
people.
Others argue that the animators intentionally
wrote a naughty word in the sky.
But we’ll let you be the judge on this one.
The Wolf of Wall Street
Before she became a member of the Suicide
Squad, Margot Robbie was mixing it up with
a different breed of criminal: The Wolf of
Wall Street.
As Naomi, the actress works opposite Leonardo
DiCaprio’s Jordan Belfort and wreaks her
own kind of havoc on his life.
When the man who has everything encounters
Naomi, she refuses to let herself get wrapped
around his little finger.
The character is insanely sexy, has no qualms
about letting her appearance do the talking.
And as a result, there are a couple of scenes
that are far more likely to get put on pause
than others.
Wild Things
After its release in 1998, Wild Things made
a big splash with audiences.
And in a roundabout way, you could say it’s
because of the character… development.
Some critics say that if it weren’t for
all the boobies, the movie would have been
a total flop.
And in reality, there are a lot of things
you can say that about.
While the sexy interactions may seem tame
by today’s standards, the film caused lot
of controversy at the time.
Constant rewinding and pausing can take its
toll on a VHS tape, and we’re willing to
bet that there are more than a few broken
copies of this flick laying around.
How many of these scenes are you guilty of
obsessing over?
Join the conversation in the comments, and
check out our channel.
If you like what you see, subscribe!
And sign up for alerts so that when we post
a new video, you’ll be the first one to
know.
Thanks for watching.